[Musique]
bienvenue dans le débat sur france 24
consacrait à l'entrevue entre les
manuels macro et vladimir poutine le
président français est à moscou pour
tenter de désamorcer la crise de
craignent n alors que cent mille soldats
russes sont toujours postés à la
frontière de l'ukraine emmanuel macron
est le premier dirigeant occidental de
premier plan a rencontré le président
russe depuis l'accroissement des
tensions une visite jugée très
importante selon porte-parole du kremlin
demain mardi le président français se
rendra à kiev pour rencontrer le
président ukrainien zelensky le
chancelier allemand olaf schulze et
quant à lui à washington alors que peut
obtenir emmanuel macron comment cette
entrevue est elle perçue à kiev à moscou
et washington quel est l'impact de ce
ballet diplomatique sur le président
futur candidat à l'élection
présidentielle
y at il une diplomatie européenne
possible autour de la question
l'ukrainien nom de débats avec mes
invités j'ai le plaisir d'avoir à mes
côtés isabelle mandraud bonsoir soit
vous êtes chef adjointe du service
international du monde ancienne
correspondante à moscou également
coauteur avec julien theron de poutine
la stratégie du désordre et c'est aux
éditions tallandier bienvenue à vous
avec nous également à pierre servant
bonsoir à vous expert en stratégie
militaire hauteur de 50 nuance de guerre
et c'est chez robert laffont
parce qu'elle nous avons le plaisir
d'avoir avec nous bruno tertrais bonsoir
directeur adjoint de la fondation pour
la recherche stratégique bienvenue à
vous
nous avons également en direct de kiev
tetyana hoggar kova bonsoir journaliste
responsable du département international
as you cry crysis media center bienvenue
à vous également dans le débat avant de
démarrer cette discussion on va voir que
modèle mâcon a dit c'est ce qu'il a
annoncé qu'il espérait amorcé une
désescalade dans la crise ukrainienne il
veut commencer le président français à
bâtir une réponse utile collectivement
at il dit pour la russie et pour tout le
reste de l'europe on va regarder le tout
premiers échanges entre les deux chefs
d'état c'était il ya un petit moment
tout premiers échanges avant le reste de
ce débat
je vois aussi que les autorités
présentes le président français
appliquent de gros efforts pour régler
la crise relative à la sécurité
européenne
dans une perspective historique
cela concerne aussi les sujets relatifs
au règlement de la crise ukrainienne à
l'est du pays je crois que notre
continent est aujourd'hui dans une
situation de le rappeler éminemment
critiques qui nous impose d'être tous et
toutes extrêmement responsables nous
avions jeté les bases nous avons jeté
les bases ensemble d'un dialogue
ce dialogue est nécessaire car c'est le
seul qui permet à mes yeux de bâtir une
vraie sécurité stabilité pour le
continent européen il avait le mans
droit là on voit cette mise en scène
tout de même c'est peut-être assez rare
de se retrouver tout seul avec vladimir
poutine pour emmanuel macron ou pour un
chef d'état de mer général puisqu'il
n'ya il ya les deux et les deux
traducteurs c'est tout non c'est pas
c'est pas la première fois que deux
responsables tels que monsieur poutine
est un l'un de ses invités se retrouvent
seules ou en tout cas en petit comité
par en revanche ce qu'il faut noter
c'est la longueur de la table qui est
déjà en elle même tout un symbole sur
l'éloignement en fait de la russie avec
avec un homologue européen ou et en
l'occurrence français cette table là a
été déjà expérimenté par viktor orban ya
quelques jours en revanche quand il a
reçu le président argentin il n'y avait
pas cette distance là donc voyez déjà
dans le symbole on est déjà dans le dans
l'éloignement volontaires montre et
démonstratif mois au tertre est pas
obtenir mais elle macron c'est qu'il a
parlé plusieurs fois vladimir poutine
est ce qui prend le risque de ne rien
obtenir après tout
oui bien sûr c'est toujours un risque
vous savez sûrement pas de risque on ne
fait pas de diplôme et si dans les
crises je crois que a minima il pourra
au moins obtenir cet entretien qui est
quasiment seul à seul il pourrait
obtenir des impressions les impressions
sont précieuses sur l'état d'esprit d'un
dirigeant qui est isolé plus isolé qui
les vivent également dans une bulle
sanitaire en ce moment qu'il vous très
peu très peu de monde et très peu de
leaders je crois que même un entretien
d'une heure ou plus porter quelque chose
sur l'état d'esprit les led mis un petit
qui en ce moment est un sujet
d'interrogation pour le monde entier je
ne crois pas qu'il y aura d'accord
triomphale disant ça y est la crise est
réglée je ne suis même pas cieux qu'il y
aura des pistes réel tracé fameuse d
escalade du conflit mais encore une fois
je crois que le principal c'est les
impressions générales que menait macro
rapportera je mettais les écrits du
président russe s'est déjà très précieux
pierres servant cent mille soldats
russes 1 sont toujours postés à la
frontière de l'ukraine quand on lit le
washington post à ne serait-ce qu hier
en une les américains préviennent de
l'imminence d'une attaque russe de
grande envergure qui pourrait faire
cinquante mille morts dit le washington
post renverser le gouvernement acquiert
selon les renseignements ce que dit le
quotidien et l'armée américaine
e on peut pas dire qu'il voit vraiment
une fenêtre d'opportunité pour la
diplomatie
non effectivement alors je rejoins ce
que disait bruno tertrais moi je suis
tout à fait favorable à toutes les
rencontres diplomatiques que l'on peut
vouloir dans cette situation très
difficile le président bak on s'est déjà
entretenu trois fois avec le président
poutine alors est-ce que le contact
physique at-elle distance va rajouter
quelque chose je ne suis pas certain
donc je pense que rien ne va sortir sur
le plan diplomatique sur le plan
militaire
moi je suis très préoccupé je pense que
l'option militaire est dans la tête de
poutine déjà depuis plusieurs mois et
que c'est pour cela qu'il n'ya pas de
vraie séquence diplomatique ouverte
maintenant attention à ne pas balancer
des tas de scénarii en disant voilà ça
vaillant une invasion ou telle chose
pourquoi dans tous les systèmes vous
avez une armée forte vous avez un
département particulier au sein de
l'état major des armées qui fait de la
planification et qui donc propose au
président da aux chefs d'état en
l'occurrence poutine plusieurs options
qui partent de la plus légère entre
guillemets
la plus lourde donc ça devrait être une
des options alors décrit le washington
post voilà sauf que là le washington
post sort s'il voulait l'option la plus
la plus à plus la pl plus les plus
importantes alors qu'il peut y avoir des
tas de gradation
entre les cyberattaques qui ont déjà
commencé qui peuvent s'accentuer vous
pouvez avoir des opérations de forces
spéciales vous savez qu une des
préoccupations de poutine et c'est ce
qui fait que je pense que poutine est
dans une option de d'opérations
militaires est pas du tout diplomatique
c'est qui s'est rendu compte que au
donbass l'armée ukrainienne avait
notamment grâce aux drôles de la
possibilité de retourner peut-être la
situation militaire donc il y avait une
vraie préoccupation poutine vous
pourriez avoir des opérations de forces
spéciales des commandos qui ré détruire
les sites de drones ou les sites de
missiles anti chars qui ont été fournis
et vous peut avoir tout ça échelonné
jusqu'à des incursions terrestres
notamment j'avais évoqué la région de
marioupol il ya un objectif stratégique
intéressant pour poutine autour de la
mer d'azov avec toujours un objectif la
mer noire parce que là vous parlez de
des forces positionnées en ukraine mais
il faut parler de la mer noire vous avez
une agitation de la marine russe cette
invitation a dévié elles peuvent être
introduits avec emmanuel macron peut
remettre en question des plans à mon
seul objectif stratégique de poutine non
moi je suis persuadé qui va aller à
l'option militaire on parle de du mois
de mars parce que ce sera à la fin des
jeux paralympiques
parce qu'il veut pas perturber son grand
ami démocrate jingping en chine mais
donc vous aurez c'est pour ça vous avez
des fausses négociations diplomatiques
de la part de poutine espèces
d'agitation vous mettriez cette entrevue
et dans les fausses négociations
puisqu'il veut pas dire que s'il n'y est
pas respectée la démarche que le
président français essaye de faire mais
je pense qu'on est dans une
gesticulation total car depuis des
semaines il n'y a aucun signe tangible
d'une volonté de poutine d'entrer dans
une séquence diplomatique
une vraie séquence diplomatique tetiana
ang à coarraze que vous êtes d'accord
vous êtes l'ukrainienne de ce débat
comment réagissent et ukrainiens à ce
qu' il ya une fenêtre d'opportunité dans
ces discussions entre vladimir poutine
et manuellement tron oui bonsoir a en
effet on observe de très près ce que
parce se passe en ukraine bien sûr on
observe la situation qui est extrêmement
ton dieu on se souvient en pas décision
auscitains dieu je serais plutôt
d'accord avec l'expert militaire qui dit
que le danger il est bien réel et
j'ajouterais seulement que pas seulement
les forces russes sont sur le dos de
base ou bien qu'ils peuvent attaquer la
mer d'azov on y voit aussi des forces
importantes qui se cumulent deux côtés
nord c'est-à-dire un bel euro 6 merci
qui est l'état qui devient de plus en
plus en état satellite de volodymyr
poutine et donc trois points de
rassemblement de troupes militaires un
vieux de des entraînements étaient
signalés et c'est seulement 50
kilomètres de la frontière ukrainienne
il faut savoir que la frontière entre la
russie et l'ukraine est une frontière
carrément inexistante donc c'est à dire
on attend on peut prêter serment
attendre des des coudes et tous les
côtés en quelque sorte et bien sûr je
serai aussi d'accord de dire que
diplomatie bas volodymyr routine a déjà
reçu une réponse bien clair et bien
strictes de l'otan et la france je vous
rappelle vous savez très bien qu'il
était aussi signataire signataires de de
cette réponse de l'otan a ajouté
attendre de boutines août et le grand
nom à tous les trois demandes de poutine
c'est à dire un non à l'élargissement de
l'otan la question du crâne et georgi
etc et le revoilà le retrait des lots
tân dung et frontières de 97 c'était non
et donc on voit que les troupes on reste
là on voit bien sûr où certains un
certain assouplissement je dirais telle
rhétorique dit poutine parce que 12 de
son ministre lavrov mais aucun signe
réel de fait qu'il veut négocier et que
la voie diplomatique que donner quelque
chose et nous les ukrainiens temps
connaît un état de guerre à partir de
2014 on a déjà l'habitude de croire au
fait aux actions non pas aux
déclarations puisque les déclarations -
est-ce suffisant isabelle boudreau est
ce qu'il peut en sortir quelque chose de
cette cette entrevue entre emmanuel
macron et et vladimir poutine en sachant
que le new york post il arrive de pékin
où il a passé quand même d'accord avec
xi jingping contre l'élargissement de
l'eau temps avec un accord également sur
le gaz russe avec pékin ressortir
quelque chose l alliance des nouveaux
pays démocrates comme ils seront
présentés effectivement est un signal
c'est un signal que eux
ils font front ils font face en tout cas
à à l'occident et qu'ils ont bien
l'intention et à l'ordre international
d'ailleurs qu'ils ont qu'ils veulent
remettre en cause tout simplement ses
dirigeants de ces deux dirigeants donc
moi je n'attends pas grand chose de
cette rencontre entre le dit mr poutine
et emmanuel macron
l'un et l'autre en ont besoin en fait de
cette rencontre va nuire poutine pour
dire que lui il est toujours ouvert la
discussion bien entendu et emmanuel
macron parce qu'en plus il est dans une
campagne électorale aujourd'hui il a
besoin en fait
d'apparaître
d'agir de faire quelque chose en tout
cas en plus il préside aujourd'hui il a
la présidence française de l'union
européenne donc et il y va et et c'est
tout à fait effectivement logique dans
sonde dans sa démarche mais si on attend
plus électorale y jouer que potentiel
faiseur de paix
il voudrait être le faiseur de paix mais
je pense pas que bologne en continuant
donne l'occasion en tout cas et donc il
est dans une démarche effectivement qui
est importante je voudrais juste a
ajouté qu'il n'y a pas seulement
l'ukraine en fait qui est la sécurité de
l'europe qui est un dossier très
important pour emmanuel matheron il y à
aussi ce qui se passe en afrique avec
les wagner qui qui sont dans de beaucoup
de pays le mali c'est un autre grossier
très difficile très sensible pour le
candidat président français et donc
c'est c'est aussi à mon âme une question
qui va aborder avec l'as dit martine
bruno tertrais ce qu'on pourrait dire
quel mac on est un peu naïf
film cesse de répéter depuis déjà trois
ou quatre ans qu'il n'est pas seulement
un naïf il le dit littéralement je ne
suis pas naïf je sais ce qu'il a réussi
je sais ce qui plaît il alors moi je
trouve ça toujours curieux parce que
quand on est simplement besoin de le
répéter tout le temps mais prenons le au
mot en revanche j'ai un tout petit
désaccord une petite nuance analyse avec
votre consoeur isabelle motrot dont
j'apprécie énormément le
bon d'accord mais je crois vraiment pas
que et qu'il classe fait la dimension
électoraliste soit importante ici ou
emmanuel pas con pour deux raisons
d'abord c'est une mission risquée et que
s'il revient les mains vides on peut
dire c'est un échec france est isolée
c'était un
deuxième temps de manière générale dans
les campagnes électorales françaises on
a beaucoup plus de comprendre que nos
points gagnés en politique étrangère et
si vous plus investira sur cette ligne
plus il encore à leurs proches d'eux
mais il ne s'occupe pas de nous les
français il cherche à régler les achats
du monde alors que c'est nous qui avons
besoin de l'attention présidentielle non
je ne crois vraiment pas que sa démarche
soit électoralistes bien sûr le fait
d'apparaître comme un chef d'état qui
compte sur le sur la scène européenne et
les kinés le sud égal à égal et poutine
j'ai tellement hâte anodin je crois
encore une fois qu'il y ait davantage
pour lui à perdre qu'à gagner à
s'investir dans cette affaire sur le
plan de la future campagne
présidentielle on va écouter d'ailleurs
dans un petit instant les réactions des
politiques parce que c'est vrai qu'on
est à deux mois de cette élection pierre
servant juste un mot sur ce qu'a pu dire
m&l macron dans le jdd il évoque enfin
l'elysée évoque une indivisibilité de la
sécurité ils disent que c'est un concept
sur lequel aucun état ne peut faire
n'importe quoi sans en subir les
conséquences
mails macron souhaite avancer vers un
nouvel ordre en europe qui repose sur le
principe d'égalité entre les états
est-ce que poutine peut l'entendre non
non non je ne pense pas je pense que
poutine est vraiment dans une autre
logique
qui est une logique ancien qui s'est
construite pendant année après année clé
poutine poutine commence à prendre de
l'âge il est encore très jeune à 68 ans
santes 9 maintenant mais il prend de
l'âge et j'ai souvent dit que il se
positionner comme un personnage
messianique autoproclamé c'est à dire le
nouveau messie tsariste de la russie
c'est à dire que dans son projet il n'y
a pas seulement tout ce qu'on voit il ya
véritablement une mission historique qui
s'est donné pour son pays et cette
mission que ce soit juste ou injuste
pour moi c'est profondément injuste et
inadapté à la question que vous posiez
par rapport
système de sécurité collectif il n'est
pas dans cette approche il est dans une
approche de domination de restauration
d'une certaine façon de ce fameux
étranger proche qui à l'époque tsariste
russie était conquise par la force
l'union soviétique grande puissance
coloniale l'a fait également il peut
plus le faire de la même façon mais par
d'autres biais il veut s'en est cette
vision du monde entre complètement ce
s'entrechoquent avec ce que mâcon
propose qui est pourtant intéressant il
ya des tas de sujets sur la table sur
les missiles à portée intermédiaire sur
les forces conventionnelles sur open sky
il ya enfin il y aurait vraiment matière
à le faire mais je crois que c'est là où
il ya un dialogue de sourds qui se joue
au moment où nous nous parlons pas le
nôtre mais celui de poutine et makro ils
sont sur deux planètes différentes
en tout cas c'est vrai que ça fait
réagir à les différents candidats à
l'élection présidentielle on va écouter
eric zemmour est également yannick jadot
moi j'aurais aimé que le président
macron commence par kiev on commence à
praia ans je sais mais qu'on commence
par la victime et non pas par
l'agresseur
il a raison d'y aller même si c'est un
peu tard et même si tous les échos que
j'ai me disent qu'en fait tout il n'a
pas confiance en lui et ça fait
longtemps qu'on me le dis je pense que
manuel mâcon a gâché ses chances à
gâcher même de bonnes idées je me
souviens du emmanuel macron recevant
vladimir poutine à versailles je peux
dire que ça avait de la gueule et que
c'était une bonne initiative
mais malheureusement comme d'habitude
avec emmanuel macron il gâche tout parce
qu'il fait tout et son contraire
tetiana hoggar kova il aurait dû aller
d'abord à kiev avant moscou et des
maquereaux bah écoutez monsieur je fais
tout un débat mais il faut dire qu on
observe tout en crescendo diplomatique à
kyiv toutes ces dernières semaines on
voit pas mal de tête des chefs d'état et
puis d'autres hauts diplomates qui qui
arrive à qui est vrai ça mon a reçu le
premier ministre britannique les
polonais on a beau sur le président turc
on va recevoir le chancelier allemand la
semaine prochaine il va d'abord se
rendre à kiev ensuite il va se rendre à
moscou on comprend que président macron
voulait d'abord voir à volodimir poutine
sans doute pour proposer puisque les
parler quand même d'un projet des
propositions qu'il allait lui faire et
peut-être qu'elle s'avance pour parler
ensuite avec président irin ski mais je
voudrais souligner que pour le crème
déjà la visite du président français
c'est qu'un c'est ce n'est pas banal
puisque ça fait 24 ans que lui craint
que qui hier n'a pas reçu le président
français donc on se félicite et puis on
espère que les changes qu'on va avoir
demandé sera introductif et qui sera
déjà avec des éléments de discussion
comme emmanuel macron appart apportera
de mousse et donc vous attendez tout de
même quelque chose de cette visite des
macros demain à kiev isabelle mandraud
est ce que ça donne une posture
internationale mail macron tout même en
pleine campagne électorale
je vais reprendre un peu la discussion
brûlot
en fait oui il en a besoin parce que
n'aurait-on dit s'il n'avait pas s'il
n'avait pas fait quelque chose puisque
effectivement il a toujours prôné une
sorte de dialogue même s'il n'est pas
naïf même s'il est assez lui et de
maquereau a toujours prôné un dialogue
avec avec poutine donc il ya aussi une
chose le chancelier allemand au sol ça
va y aller olafsen vieillit les dans
quelques jours donc s'il n'y avait pas
été que n'aurait-on dit en disant bas
alors la france de toute manière elle
pèse rien n'a jamais pesé enfin voilà
encore l'image de la france qui est
dégradée sur niveau international donc
sa cliente électoralement ça compte
électoralement même si ça ne pas le poid
effectivement des préoccupations
quotidiennes des français dans une
campagne ça on est bien d'accord mais
sur l'image de la france ça compte
énormément et encore une fois il ya
aussi sûre il a deux dossiers qui sont
très sensibles il a ce dossier de la
sécurité en europe d'ailleurs parce que
ça ne concerne pas seulement la russie
ou l'ukraine mais ça concerne tout la
sécurité en europe on voit bien que les
pays baltes on voit bien qu'à pologne
etc sont extrêmement inquiets de cette
situation et ils font partie de l'union
européenne dont il ya ce dossier là et
il ya le dossier encore une fois l'autre
dossier sensible qui est l'humiliation
de la retraite française au mali et qui
est en qui n'est pas sans rapport avec
la russie bruno tertrais c'est vrai que
ça lui donne tout de même une posture
internationale dans cette campagne
électorale que de d'avoir ce tête à tête
avec d'admir poutine même si ça reste
d'après ce que dit pierre servant à un
dialogue de sourds l'image débat est
peut-être aura peut-être un impact sur
cette campagne
je suis réconcilié le conduisent à une
longue mandraud et le mien quoi qu'ils
fassent gilles façon il sera attaqué et
quoi qu'ils fassent en politique
étrangère cela sera à tort ou à raison
de bonne foi ou de mauvaise foi vous
dites ça change et des mois d'expérience
tout simplement écouter ce qu'on regarde
les l'historique des 30 dernières années
et la manière dont les prises dans la
limite jusqu'ici chez les candidats
excès au présentiel réagissent ce
l'était son politique étrangère ça ne
fait aucun doute dans mon esprit il
avait encore une fois raison de le faire
mais je pense qu'il prend en crise et à
tout prendre je pense que le risque est
moins
resté à paris plutôt qu'à faire une
visite que le monde entier suit ce soir
une équipe probablement le résultat ce
n'est pas l'essentiel essentiel ce jour
que le président malawite et sincère ils
pensent réellement avoir un rôle une
chance parce qu'ils étaient mal
parce que la france doit jouer selon lui
ce rôle qui est celui de la puissance d'
équilibre sur lequel j'ai
personnellement mais en tout cas je veux
un instant et c'est peut-être le
principal qu'il soit sincère dans sa
démarche car ça avant il est sincère
dans sa démarche qui se présente comme
un faiseur de paix mondiale ça profite
aux futurs candidats macron alors il
faut dire corps en matière politique
sauf si ça ne marche pas peut-être voilà
c'est toujours compliqué de d'analysé
dans le cerveau la part de la sincérité
et je crois qu'elle y est qu'elle y est
et y pensant plus qu'il a vraiment des
capacités personnelles de conviction
d'emporter le morceau de c'est quelque
chose qui est structurelle chez lui
c'est un homme qui a remporté des défis
impossibles à remplir d'eau que je pense
que là il ya une partie sincère et puis
peut y avoir une partie de calcul entre
guillemets qui fait que quand il est
positionné comme ça tous les autres
apparaissent comme bien pâlots sont là à
dire faudra est pas le faire faudra le
faire etc mais un point sur lequel je
veux insister peut-être en lien ce que
bruno tertrais a dit c'est que c'est
vrai que l'international ne pèse pas
beaucoup dans les campagnes électorales
mais il faut président mac on prend un
risque dans le sens où y ait eu la faire
des sous marins australiens le contrat
qu'on a perdu alors les français voient
un peu ça passait comme ça mais ils ont
quand même le sentiment qu'on s'est fait
un peu à voir dans cette affaire la
force et c'est le cas oui clairement
mais je parle de la perception que d'un
peu atténué s'ils voulaient
effectivement les gens qui sont en
difficulté sur l'heureux leur poids le
le le etc c'est pas mais le problème
c'est la séquence il ya ça le mali le
mali l'ambassadeur de france viré et je
suis frappée d'une chose qui n'a pas été
soulignée 72 heures pour partir c'est le
tarif appliqué aux espions quand on
n'explique re un diplomate 72 heures
c'est quand c'est un espion en général
quand c'est un diplomate à vrai
diplomate on ne met pas la porte aussi
rapidement donc il ya une humiliation ce
détail n'est pas perçue par l'opinion
publique mais fait que le mali où 53
soldats français sont morts pour la
souveraineté pour se couvrir le mali se
fait virer de cette façon c'est quand
même pas terrible et là sur la séquence
russe si le président français rentrent
sans rien ça construit quelque chose que
ses opposants vont utiliser on va dire
mais vous bossez du col mais regardez
cette séquence catastrophique de votre
diplomatie donc je pense qu'il prend un
risque mais en même temps il pense qu'il
est à la hauteur de l'histoire et dans
ce sens il a raison parce que vous savez
ce qu'ils jouent là c'est l'histoire je
veux dire par là que les historiens dans
30 ans regardons notre émission pour
voir si on s'est complètement plantée
sur l'analyse ou si on a été dans juste
il avait le moindre votre analyse or ce
n'est pas la première fois que emmanuel
macron voix blian poutine vous l'aviez
dit il avait il avait reçu à versailles
en 2017 puis au fort brégançon en 2019
il a été reçu lui-même me semble-t-il à
saint pétersbourg il voulait donc lancé
ce dialogue avec le président russe
depuis le début on a l'impression que
cette politique d'équilibré modèle
macron franchement n'a pas vraiment
obtenu de succès auprès de valiant
poutine assez moins qu'on puisse dire en
fait à chaque fois chaque fois la
déception a été au rendez vous en tout
cas du côté du côté du côté de macron à
chaque fois même encore une fois il fait
à versailles il reçoit macron il lui dit
aussi les cas de vérité puisque on sort
de la diction française il ya une
gérance russe dans l'élection française
assez assez prononcé donc il lui dit
quand même il leur soit très bien mais
il lui dit quand même ensuite il ya
l'épisode brégançon donc la brillance
ont encore une fois formés dans le
contexte est à la veille du g7 ou d'où
la russie n'est plus donc en geste de
bonne volonté il invite et il invite
bien la dîmière peut aussi dans
brégançon mais enfin je veux dire
quelques mois plus tard toute l'europe
tous et toutes les démocraties disait
c'est épouvantable un opposant été
assassiné il faut l'exfiltrer en
allemagne on va prendre des sanctions et
que c'était ya jamais eu autant
d'expulsions
de diplomates entre l'occident et la
russie que ces dernières années donc à
chaque fois ce sont des attentes déçues
à chaque fois manuel da cruz n'a rien
reçu de boutines bruno tertrais c'est
vrai que ce sont une accumulation c'est
une accumulation de déceptions comme
l'expliquent isabelle mandraud ce rendez
vous avec vladimir poutine qui l'a mis
quasiment immédiatement après avoir été
élu sur la table et même macron oui
c'est vrai je suis autant que moi
beaucoup critiqué les illusions de la
france de macron visa ville de l'ennemi
un coutil je suis d'autant plus à l'aise
possible je crois que les efforts qu'il
a consentis conserve une certaine vertu
premièrement vous souvenez tous les
débats d'année 2010 et demie vie ou la
moitié du corps politique et
intellectuel français disent elles il
faut parler à la russie parlons plus
assez à l'argile au moins ce qu'a fait
ma course a permis de tuer cet argument
de certaine manière regardez en parle
tout le temps avec la russie vous voyez
bien qu'il ne suffit pas de parler de
dialoguer avec la russie pour obtenir
des résultats deuxièmement ce que disent
les
officiels français qui vante à moscou y
compris les représentants six questions
du président de la république
ils disent que même s'il n'y a pas de
résultat spectaculaire
il ya connaissance des interlocuteurs
russes est ce qu'on peut apprendre
certains domaines sensibles le domaine
si mr par exemple on obtient quand même
des petites choses valables à parler
d'eux même si encore une petite chose
valable bruno tertrais
d'avoir ya des choses dont je ne
souhaite pas parler ici et ensuite il ya
mille puissant tout simplement est par
ailleurs mon premier argument consiste à
dire que la connaissance des
interlocuteurs les chiens côté la
connaissance mutuelle est extrêmement
importante en diplomatie c'est
fondamental et on a raison de continuer
à parler à tous les niveaux du niveau
présidentiel au niveau des
administrations avec nos homologues
russes parce que mym qui même sur le
petit rien je le connais c'est
extrêmement important aussi les
comprendre de même prévoir et si
possible de gérer les cheese tête à
hoggar kova est-ce que emmanuel macron à
raison d'avoir depuis le début voulu
dialoguer avec poutine même si on se
rend bien compte que ce dialogue
entraîné un certain nombre de déceptions
du côté de la france va écouter vue de
l'ukraine ce qui compte aussi c'est pas
seulement les dialogues les tête à tête
entre macro poutine aux autres
présidents avec poutine mais on n'a rien
dit sur le format de dôme indique qu'ils
étaient à la base de régler ces
questions à daniel basse le format très
important qu'ils étaient lancés en 2015
et qui aboutit à un grand échec n'est ce
pas parce que tout simplement on chez
poutine n'a pas vous vous continuez ce
format aujourd'hui on parle des petites
reprises il y a deux semaines quatre
conseillers politiques se sont vus à
paris justement le représentant kényan
russe français et allemand on parle un
tout petit peu de manière précoce de
dans l'espoir de faire revivre ce format
mais finalement format normandie qui
était à l'acquitter au format à régler
au mettre en place si vous voulez le
protocole de minsk le fameux protocole
de minsk n'a pas apporté de résultats
pour la sambre absence de volonté
politique du monsieur poutine de régler
ce problème puisque selon poutine
l'ukraine en tant que pays indépendant
en tant que l'état indépendant n'existe
pas je vous renvoie à son article écrit
en it et 2021 où l'écrit clairement que
le prince est en fouettant etc c'est un
seul peuple est en fête avec les russes
donc à ses yeux l'ukraine n'existe pas
donc il va pas régler le problème avec
ça et donc le risque le risque qu'on n'a
pas évoqué aujourd'hui mais que je veux
qu'on retienne que la visite de manuel
mac os et de chancelier chose que ne
relance pas il ya les volontés de
l'allemagne et de la france de ne régler
la de mettre en place la version on va
dire la lecture russe du protocole du
mix ça c'est un vrai danger ce sera le
prix de compromis avec poutine ça c'est
une chose qu'on croit beaucoup en
ukraine justement et ça a peut-être ça
représente un danger réel pierse avant
justement on va reparler de ce protocole
normandie un désaccord de minsk et olaf
scholz ah non je le rappelle est
aujourd'hui à washington mails macron
sera à berlin juste après kiev
d'ailleurs le président polonais sera
aussi en allemagne et même après on sait
qu'il veut réimposer l'europe dans le
débat avec cette réouverture également
du processus normandie à paris est ce
qu'il ya une diplomatie européenne
possible oui et non un peu une réponse
de normand oui parce qu'on voit bien que
les européens le président français
président qui à la présidence tournante
de l'union européenne se déploie vous
avez des déclarations des propositions
tentative de 2,2 de ressusciter cette
diplomatie européenne qui a été
totalement ce quiz et le poutine qui ne
souhaitait pas en fait dit ce n'est pas
ce qu'est la sela ou si vous voulez si
le jeu de comptines ces déclarations
sont quand même très clair je veux dire
vraiment être totalement séduits par la
personne de poutine et avoir un poster
de poutine dans sa chambre pour ne pas
regarder les faits les déclarations les
options etc il ya un point donc si vous
voulez oui il ya une volonté de s'agiter
mais l'autre côté il faut bien voir que
vladimir poutine a pour l'union
européenne un mépris total mépris total
l'admirent poutine méprisable macron
aussi il considère que tous ces chefs
d'état que l'union européenne est
devenue une espèce de ventre mou qui a
totalement abandonné les grandes valeurs
de l'europe chrétienne qui est aux mains
des feymen des minorités etc il a un
mépris total pour l'union européenne et
qu'est-ce qui fait dans sa fosse
séquence diplomatique il discutait que
les américains qui n'ont qu'une envie
c'est pas ces deux surtout plus
s'occuper de l'europe dont qui les
ramène dans le champ et il discute avec
l'otan comme organisation mais l'union
européenne n'ont donc c'est ça et
dernier point très rapidement si vous
regardez aussi les décisions en matière
militaire pas simplement concernant
l'ukraine la biélorussie
c'est à dire le fait de mettre à
kaliningrad dont cette espèce cette
enclave territoriales russes qui est
donc coincé entre la lituanie la pologne
10 mètres des missiles iskander qui
peuvent emporter des têtes nucléaires
bruno tertrais est un excellent
spécialiste des problématiques nucléaire
poutine utilise régulièrement et ses
proches le chantage du nucléaire pour
appuyer ses buts dont 6 nés quand vous
voyez ça qu'après on dit séquence
diplomatique
non moi je ne vois pas de vraie séquence
diplomatique je vois pas pas un discours
une construction une agitation sur la
scène avec des différents séquençage je
vous rappelle quand même qu'il a détruit
1 mis un satellite d'observation dans la
stratosphère parra tirs militaires dont
vous avez tout ça est le point d'arrivée
de cela ça sera des opérations
militaires de quelle ampleur je ne sais
pas isabelle mandraud même diplomatie
européenne le président baydan affirme
qu'il veut travailler de manière proche
avec avec le chancelier allemand au la
chose qui en ce moment même à washington
il y a tout de même est-ce que sont pas
les divisions européennes tout de même à
ce que les européens ne sont pas aussi
responsable de ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui c'est un peu compliqué parce
que moi je suis frappé par en fait la
différence de perception entre pays
européens sire que vous avez des pays
scandinaves baltes polonais qui sont ou
les où les ce qui faisait partie en fait
des pays satellites de l'ancienne urss
qui sont qui ont une vraie angoisse
alors que nous on ne réussit pas du tout
la même façon c'est-à-dire que nous le
l'ancienne europe de l'ouest finalement
on reste un petit peu dans le voile à la
négociation le terrain diplomatique
l'allemagne c'est un peu le ventre mou
aussi de cette europe l'allemagne qui a
adopté une attitude très très réservé
par rapport à cette situation a été
énormément critiqué justement par tous
ces pays là donc c'est pas on parle
toujours de l'europe divisée etc mais là
c'est une différence de perception est
presque de ce sentiment par rapport à
par rapport à ce que la russie ou la
menace que représente la russie mais
regardez les pays scandinaves qu'un pays
comme la suède qui se réarment qui
réinstalle son son service militaire qui
se déploie et déploie son armée sur une
ligne d'une l'île de gotland voilà c'est
pas seulement les pays baltiques pour y
être allé récemment je peux vous assurer
que pour eux c est tout d'un coup il
voit arriver la russie à leurs
frontières c'est une menace russe c'est
la menace russe pour re pour ea
représente beaucoup plus que pour nous
ça c'est clair que les français ou les
espagnols les italiens au moins ce
sentiment d'urgence en fait donc il ya
une perception qui est déjà différente
après ça veut pas dire qui a pas que
qu'on ne peut pas parler ou tirer dans
le même sens mais il ya quand même à la
base déjà une perception qui est
différente et ça c'est un problème que
bruno tertrais justement sur ces
divisions ça aux fans l'europe au la
chose donc et aux états unis en ce
moment à washington l'a vu joe biden on
a l'impression où joe biden essaye de
mettre un peu la pression sur le
chancelier parce qu'effectivement sur
les sanctions par exemple à l'égard de
la russie s'était plutôt tiède des
allemands et en l'occurrence olaf scholz
et en particulier sur cette histoire
tout ce qui concerne l'oléoduc le fameux
oléoduc north stream 2 puisque les états
unis voudraient justement que ça soit un
des points pas qu'on coupe carrément cet
oléoduc si justement il y as sanctions
contre vladimir poutine
mais ce qui ne change rien au problème
est ce que vous disiez un instant
le lot robe l'union européenne est nulle
part mais les européens sont partout moi
je ne vois pas d'absence de l'eau tous
les grands bisous bien et même les moins
grands on fait partie de l'effort du blé
mais font partie de l'effort automatique
et font état de leur position dans les
deux enceintes et notamment le
l'enceinte autant en russie dans
laquelle joue un rôle mais tant que
l'union européenne n'existe pas mais
construite pour faire de la diplomatie
sécuritaire avec la russie je crois
qu'il faut pas négliger le rôle
désormais bien deuxième point sur les
sanctions sur l'unité européenne je suis
d'accord visiblement bien sûr qu'il ya
une différence de perception ça commence
par la géographie ça continue à
l'histoire moi je trouve qu'on regarde
ces différences réelles perception
l'unité des européens et des pays
occidentaux en général et tout à fait
alors remarquable on est très très loin
des grandes crises transatlantique de la
guerre froide on est encore plus loin de
là crise de 2003 ou alors là est
vraiment un schisme entre les états unis
et certains pays au regard d'un côté et
la france elle m'a de l'autre à propos
la question de l'irak non je serai prêt
du fait que c'est un échec d'ailleurs
pour la russie il y à une solidarité
européenne dans les faits et pour parler
de l'allemagne puisque vous en parliez à
l'instant l'allemagne après quelques
hésitations après les votes a pris des
positions très fermes notamment sous
l'influencé de la ministre des affaires
étrangères airbag et aujourd'hui le
champ seule chose à washington à mon
avis peut faire et à le faire mais il
n'a pas besoin d'être poussés par par
monsieur maiden encore une fois je crois
qu'ils me ce qui est le plus frappant
c'est plutôt ce message d'unité malgré
les différences de perception et
quelques petits divergences sur la
stratégie à suivre mais il faut je crois
qu'il faut pas bouder notre plaisir le
solide à l'outil they know garko va vous
avez l'impression aussi vous que les
européens sont unis pour soutenir
l'ukraine aujourd'hui va écouter ce
qu'on peut dire en tout cas ce qu'on
voit les grands ference avec entre ce
moment d'aujourd'hui est le moment de
2014 ce qu'au moment 2014 ou le cren k
attaqué ou la crimée été annexées de
manière inégale par la russie ou d'une
basse était occupée on a vu toutes les
divisions et une faiblesse relative on
va dire de l'occident bien sûr y avait
des sanctions il n'y avait pas de raison
il n'y a pas deux il n'y avait pas de
réponse faire qu'ils arrêteraient
poutine à ce moment là donc ce qu'on
voit aujourd'hui on voit vraiment que
les voilà que les pieds sont très
solidaires le pirée leur or je veux dire
bien sûr avec quelques différences bien
sûr la position de l'allemagne sur le
sur les armes ne passe pas inaperçu en
ukraine et il suscite pas mal donné une
réaction très différentes mais a à la
fois on constate déjà que la réponse
déjà de l'otan était très ferme unis
ensuite la réponse européenne bon on va
pas parler de mesures hors ban qui s'est
rendu en russie récemment mais
globalement on voit que cette solaire et
solidarité autour non plus autour de
l'ukraine puisque aujourd'hui il n'est
plus question uniquement de l'ukraine
mais les questions de architecture de
sécurité un euro on voit que l'europe
devient plus dé plus en plus unie
aujourd'hui qu'il ya huit ans donc ça
c'est ça c'est en fait donc après il ya
bien sûr des avancées à faire il ya un
progrès à faire puisque on ne sait pas
où messieurs poutine va s'arrêter
puisque la logique floue sur laquelle il
agit c'est la logique de l'empiré en
fait ils s'arrêtent là où on l'arrête et
après c'est à savoir à quel prix est ce
que l'europe allait arrêter l'europe
avec le cren bien sûr va l'arrêter et où
et à quel prix pour vous pire servant il
arrêtera pas l'autre n'arrêtera pas un
vladimir poutine à vous écouter écouter
j'espère me tromper j'espère que vous
ferez inviterait et vous direz vous
regardez tout se passe maintenant voyez
tout le monde s'embrasse sur la bouche
non je craque vraiment là là là cette
logique est d'autant plus inscrits que
poutine poutine est dans une stratégie
des chèques d'échec c'est à dire que il
est en train de ressouder l'otan qui
était en état de mort cérébrale donc là
tout le monde il ramène les américains
en europe les américains n'avaient
qu'une envie c'est partir pour leur
grand combat entre guillemets contre la
chine
l'union européenne je rejoins ce qu'a
dit bruno tertrais avec des difficultés
des tensions parce qu'il faudra voir
mais ça pourra justement déboucher sur
une diplomatie avec poutine ce que vous
décrivez
avec une personne rationnelle eu
peut-être mais je craque s'ils voulaient
non pas que je dis pas que poutine est
fou et tout ça c'est un joueur d'échecs
avec une stratégie de joueurs de poker
menteur non là c'est le problème c'est
que pour l'instant les cartes qui met
sur la table mais revient en pleine
figure et que je crains que dans sa dans
sa logique et dans sa stratégie le fait
de se dire l'ukraine est perdu le cren à
la capacité éventuellement de reprendre
le dombass on est assiégé et donc il
faut continuer dans cette logique de
pression parce que finalement ces
européens et les américains sont j'avais
une image un peu trop fort bien sondé
coire sondés coire et donc je finirai
bien par apposer ma logique je crains
que cela ne le pousse aux extrêmes merci
beaucoup pierre servant remercie
beaucoup isabelle mandraud d'avoir été
avec nous merci à vous bruno tertrais
merci tetiana hoggar cover d'avoir été
avec nous en direct de kiev merci à vous
tous nous a suivis et reste avec nous
sur france 24